Narrator: We
celebrate the
risk‐takers...
Why not quit the job
and go for it?
...the idea‐makers...
We can really change
the world together.
[ Screams ]
Narrator: ...the ones who
determine their own fate.
‐Whoo!
‐We got a deal!
Narrator:
We celebrate entrepreneurs.
I want y'all to think ‐‐
Who's next?
Narrator:
This is "Shark Tank."
And tonight,
the American dream continues...
You can call me
the Easter Bunny.
That's egg‐cruciating.
[excruciating]
You can ride it
to and from the train station.
"I want to be
the next Scrub Daddy."
Stop the madness.
There's more madness!
Uh‐oh.
What are you sales?
20 bucks a month.
20 bucks a month?
Oh!
Big merchants
are going to love this.
That's crazy.
You are going
to get crushed.
♪♪
First into the tank
is a business
that hopes to be
a popular holiday tradition.
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
I love those pants.
He looks like you
in that bunny outfit.
[ Chuckles ]
Hi, Sharks.
My name
is Scott Houdashell,
but you can call me
the Easter Bunny.
And I'm Curtis McGill.
We are
from Amarillo, Texas,
and our product is
The Eggmazing Egg Decorator.
We are here
seeking $350,000
in egg‐change
for 7% egg‐quity in our company.
[ Corcoran laughs ]
Oh.
Houdashell:
Since we were kiddos...
Little baby bunnies.
...moms and dads
and grandmas and grandpas
have been using
the same old traditional methods
to decorate
Easter eggs.
It's so smelly
and messy
that some families
don't even want to bother.
Well, Sharks, we have
an egg‐cellent alternative...
[ Laughter ]
...and it's no yolk.
[joke]
No yolk.
[ Laughter ]
Say goodbye to smelly vinegar
and messy dyes.
The Eggmazing Egg Decorator
is the new, fun,
no‐mess solution
to decorate Easter eggs.
We brought along our egg‐sperts
and my kiddos.
[ Laughter ]
They're gonna show you
how it works.
Just place
a hard‐boiled egg in the opening
and turn on
your Eggmazing.
Grab a colorful marker,
and let's let the fun begin.
You just place
the tip of the marker
to the spinning egg and start
making your own designs.
Cuban: Oh, cool.
Corcoran:
It's clever.
Houdashell:
It's simple, creative...
Herjavec: Yeah!
...and it really is all the fun
without the mess.
Herjavec: Wow.
Great.
McGill: So, Sharks,
who wants to join us
and help us
change the way
families decorate
their Easter eggs?
It's Eggmazing!
Eggmazing!
[ Laughter ]
Oh, yeah.
Cute kids,
I must say.
I agree.
Give me
a blue set of ears.
Give me the pink.
What's wrong with pink?
No, because I want to be blue.
I'm a boy.
You're better in pink.
Go ahead.
[ Laughs ]
Looks fabulous.
Cuban:
Good job, guys.
McGill:
Bye, Pickle.
Hop on out of here.
Cuban: Bye.
Good job, guys.
Love you.
Greiner: Bye.
Bye, Sport.
Thanks.
So, tell us how
you dreamt this up.
It was Easter 2015,
decorating in the kitchen,
making a mess with all
the vinegar and all the dyes.
That's when I knew
there had to be a better way.
And I rounded up
a hot glue stick,
an electric screwdriver,
and a spoon.
I'm having a hard time
with the talking rabbit.
I got to tell you.
Houdashell: And I heated
a hot glue stick
and stuck it
to the top of the egg,
and stuck the other end
of that hot glue stick
in the
electric screwdriver
and just balanced it
on the spoon.
And I had Curtis,
my bestie here,
go round up
some markers.
And I pulled the trigger on it
and it started spinning,
touched a marker
to it,
and that's when I knew
I had a better mousetrap.
The problem with this is,
it's very seasonal.
I'm gonna think about this
once a year
when I'm thinking about
coloring eggs,
and then I'm gonna forget
about it for the rest of time.
How are we gonna make any money
selling this only once a year?
Well, we, uh ‐‐ we asked ourself
that same question.
I hope so.
The first of this last year,
we went down the journey,
two years
of development,
and we got a container of them
made in China,
delivered to
his insurance office.
Mine.
We unloaded
all 10,000 of them ourself.
We didn't have anything sold
on March 1st,
and looked at each other
and said,
"That's a lot of eggs."
[ Chuckles ]
A whole lot of eggs.
We proceeded to sell them.
It took us 23 days.
How'd you do it?
We joined ASTRA,
which is a small American
toy‐retailer association.
Sent out an e‐mail blast.
They began to pick it up.
People that had ordered
two cases
called back and ordered four.
They ordered eight.
Good for you.
Congratulations.
They called back
and ordered 12.
What are your sales?
It was $150,000.
How much do you sell it for,
and what are your costs?
Back then,
it was $8.28.
Herjavec:
Your costs?
So you basically ‐‐
you made no money?
No, they made
about 50 grand.
We did all right.
Wait, wait, wait, he didn't say
what he sold it for.
What does one sell for?
It costs you $8.28.
The first run,
we sold for $19.99.
We are now $24.99.
You saw that it was
really successful at $19,
sold them all out, but
now you're taking a risk
by upping the price.
It was actually ‐‐
Well, it was actually
higher than that.
A lot of the retailers
sold them for more,
but on Amazon, the average
retail price was $59.
O'Leary: Oh!
What?!
Corcoran:
You got to be kidding.
Sorry, people were buying it
from you and upselling it?
People paid $59
for it?
One went on eBay
for $120.
Yeah!
That's awesome!
Greiner:
Wait, wait, wait.
They began to go up
as the demand went up.
Did people give you preorders
for the next Easter ‐‐
the guys who couldn't get
their hands on it?
Right now, we have $1.2 million
in purchase orders.
[ Cuban laughs ]
What?!
And that is starting
next spring, your price.
Whoa!
At what price?
$4.71, landed.
What do you
wholesale it for?
$12.50, wholesale.
O'Leary: $12.50.
Are these
a one‐way order?
In other words,
in the toy industry...
They're a one‐way order.
I'm staring to like you.
What do you mean
by "one‐way order"?
Meaning they can't return it.
They can't return it.
So, understand
that those P. O. s,
only half of those
are for the Egg.
Wait, say that again.
Only half ‐‐
Yeah,
can you repeat that?
Herjavec: I'm sorry, Curtis.
What else would they be for?
Our sister product.
Oh, you haven't told us
about another product.
Another product?
Oh, it's ‐‐
Houdashell: Our sister product
is the
TreeMendous Ornament Decorator.
We love puns.
The TreeMendous
Ornament Decorator
is a sister product
to the Egg.
That we have no proof
of concept, in terms of sales.
We have $680,000
worth of sales.
How did you do ‐‐
Is that a one‐way sale?
One‐way purchase orders,
absolutely.
Curtis, can I see
a Christmas ornament?
Is this gonna be your first
season with the Christmas?
This is
our first season.
That ‐‐ That just got here
from our manufacturer.
Thank you.
But you don't really know
what the actual sell‐through
is going to be on those yet?
This one, we do not have
actual sell‐through yet.
Greiner:
To the consumer, right?
Cuban: Right. Right.
What do you charge
for this?
$30.
It comes with eight markers
and three ornaments.
I get
the Easter thing.
It's very intuitive
to understand what you're doing.
You're decorating an egg,
which is a long‐term tradition.
There is no tradition
to decorate
your own Christmas ornament.
Let me speak to that.
I think there's a lot of risk
on the ornaments,
and the price is high.
People spend a lot more money
at Christmas
than they do
on Easter.
The issue
with your deal
is the size of the cash
you're asking for.
$350,000 ‐‐
big number, okay?
But I'm a very, very creative
Shark, as you know.
I'm gonna
make you an offer.
I'll give you $50,000
for the equity component
of my deal.
I want 33%
of the company.
[ Laughing ]
I want to be
the third guy,
with the ‐‐
I'll wear the ears.
I'll wear the ears,
okay?
And then the $300,000
is a loan, okay?
I'm willing to do that
at 13%.
13%?! [ Laughs ]
Cuban:
Oh, Lord.
Absolutely.
That's egg‐cruciating.
13%?!
You know, I'd like to see
your offer, Robert.
We appreciate that
you've egg‐tended an offer.
Of course
you appreciate it.
It's the only offer
you've got.
[ Laughter ]
Look,
I've got three kids,
and the only thing that
I want for them is to not ‐‐
not have to see their parents
eat the crusts
off the peanut butter
and jelly sandwiches
like I had to
when I was a kid.
We've worked our whole lives
to get where we are, so ‐‐
Okay, I'll drop my interest rate
to 11%.
[ Laughs ]
I want to, uh, wholeheartedly
disagree with you,
uh, about
your Christmas idea.
I think your Christmas idea
really is not gonna fly.
I think it's very hard,
looking at that box,
to get the idea of the
spinning wheel in the middle,
which is so easy
to see here.
Be careful.
Okay,
here's what I'm gonna do.
I'll give you the $350,000
for 15%,
but I'll only give half of it
in cash
and half of it
in a credit line.
What is the interest rate
on the debt, Barbara?
Whatever is the cheapest rate
I get from my bank.
Whatever is going,
I'll give it right to you.
I'm not making money
on that.
That's about 5%
on something like this.
And if you need more money
than that, no problem.
As long as you have the orders,
I don't mind funding anything...
Yes, ma'am.
...especially when
they can't return them.
We appreciate
the offer.
O'Leary: Okay, so,
I'm willing to be flexible,
but I want
to make some money, too.
I'm ‐‐ I'm ‐‐
I'm with you.
Okay, well, look, I'll do
the, um, $300,000 debt at 7%,
and I'll give you $50,000
for 20% of the company.
[ Laughs ]
Remember,
there's only one Mr. Wonderful.
He's spinning
an egg somewhere.
Listen,
I'm gonna make you an offer.
♪♪
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in.
Curtis and Scott
have two offers on the table
for their Easter‐egg
decorating kit, Eggmazing,
but Lori is also interested.
Greiner:
I would give you $100,000,
and I'll ask for 12 1/2%.
The rest
is a line of credit.
What do you charge
on your debt?
I‐I will be 7%
as my interest rate.
And by the way,
I came here, in my heart,
uh, needing and ‐‐ and not
wanting to go any higher
than a 10% equity.
I have worked
my whole life
in carpentry
and laying tile.
Uh, my bunny knees
are worn out.
This is my capturing
lightning in a bottle,
and I'm ‐‐ I'm ready
to ride this lightning
the whole way.
You definitely have lightning
in a spinning bottle.
[ Chuckles ]
And the Easter egg thing
is taking off.
But I don't know if I see
an entire company around it.
Good luck.
I'm out.
Thank you.
I'm gonna change
my offer.
I'll give you
the $350,000
at the lowest interest rate
I can get from my bank.
I, honest to God,
don't know what that is,
but they love me 'cause
I keep a lot of cash there.
I'll give you the credit line
for 10% of the business.
Okay.
Guys,
I'm changing my offer.
$350,000 at 10% equity
and a $2 royalty
until I get paid back.
But I'm gonna give $1...
Did I hear "royalty"?
...to any charity
of your choice ‐‐
some type
of children's organization.
Name me as the charity.
I've got kids.
[ Laughter ]
So do I.
Greiner:
And then that way,
something good
is going to helping kids,
and I'm getting the guarantee,
'cause it is seasonal.
Rich.
You can't give up $2
from every unit.
That's crazy.
That's ‐‐ That is
a little difficult.
You only make
$7.50 a unit.
I actually think
my offer's better.
Guys, I think she'll do
a better job for this,
'cause she's
more product‐driven
for ‐‐ for these
kinds of things, right?
So, this isn't
a business for me.
I'm out.
♪♪
You can't give up money
from each unit.
I mean,
that's ‐‐ it ‐‐
you won't be in business
the following year.
I love
to go fast and furious
and get it out
everywhere in the market
so that if you sell
literally hundreds of thousands
of these fast,
you have plenty of margin.
This is really nothing
when you think about it.
I don't think you can afford $2.
I really don't.
I think that's too much.
You can't ‐‐
You can't do that.
It's too much.
It sounds great
and the money going to charity,
and I love that idea.
But when you're starting out
a business,
to give up $2
out of a $5 cost,
you don't want
to walk into that.
Corcoran:
I truly believe
I have the best offer on
the table that meets your needs.
You have to
really think about
what are your goals with
this business? What do
you want to accomplish?
But I have to say,
I'm gonna put ‐‐ I just
really need an answer now
because I feel like you're just
using me as a backboard,
which I'm not
comfortable with.
No.
No, ma'am.
You've got
three offers now.
What do you
want to do?
Time to make
a decision.
♪♪
Lori, we would love
to make a deal with you.
Good. Yay!
Cuban:
Congratulations.
Houdashell:
We appreciate everyone.
Take mine.
We appreciate...
[ Laughter ]
Cuban:
Congratulations, guys.
Thank you very much.
Thanks very much.
Oh.
Great. Congratulations.
Damn it.
Congratulations, guys.
Thank you all very much.
Herjavec:
Thank you, guys.
Ciao.
Congrats.
Yeah.
You can step on
the bunny ears.
I don't want them.
[ Laughs ]
You good?
Yeah,
I'm good.
[ Chuckles ]
McGill:
It means the world to me.
My best friend just ‐‐
just did what he's been
capable of all his life.
♪♪
Narrator: Only months ago,
Jason Burns made a deal
with Barbara Corcoran
for Fidgetland,
a company that makes fidget toys
that can help with ADD
and other challenges.
Let's see
what they're up to now.
Burns: All I've ever wanted
to do was help people like me
that can benefit
from using Fidgets.
In just three months,
we've sold more than I did in
the past 10 years ‐‐ $580,000.
How are you?
Hey!
Welcome to New York.
The moment I saw Jason
on "Shark Tank,"
he spoke to my heart.
When I was in school,
I was labeled the dumb kid
because I couldn't
pay attention.
I have kids
with learning differences,
and here's a guy
who believed in the solution
he held in his hand,
and I believed with him.
Now that we have
such huge demand,
we really have to
spend our money wisely.
I invited Jason here
to talk about the huge growth
the business has had
and also to speak
at my daughter Katie's school.
A fidget keeps the part of
your brain that gets bored busy,
so the other part
can pay attention and focus.
Corcoran:
I felt it was important
for Jason to come to the school,
share his story,
and inspire the kids.
Barbara talks about
how her top entrepreneurs
all have learning differences,
and I think that's because
we're great problem‐solvers.
I was a horrible student
as a kid,
and then to be invited
to come and speak at a school,
it's unbelievable.
I hope the kids understand
that they have the DNA
to be an entrepreneur.
If I could succeed,
they can definitely succeed.
Corcoran:
Thank you so much,
and let's have
a round of applause for Jason.
When you're a Shark,
it's great to make money,
but more important,
you can invest in businesses
you actually believe in.
We're not just
making dreams come true,
we're making a difference
in people's lives.
Burns: Living with ADD
and learning differences
is really challenging,
but I've learned
to overcome those challenges.
And I'm living proof
that you can be successful.
Fidgetland!     Fidgetland!
Fidgetland!          Fidgetland!
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up are sisters
who are hoping to continue
their father's legacy.
♪♪
My name
is Katherine Saltzberg.
And I'm Lauri Fraser.
Our company
is Hugo's Amazing Tape.
And we
are seeking $50,000
for 50% equity
in our company.
Wow.       Wow.
Wow.                        Wow.
5‐0?
Si, señor.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
[ Chuckles ]
And this tape
truly is amazing,
and it will solve
all of your sticky situations.
Uh‐oh.
This tape
has no adhesive,
so it sticks
to nothing...
but itself.
And it is
super‐duper strong.
Take it, Lauri.
I'll take it, Kathy.
Pull, pull, pull.
[ Laughter ]
Herjavec: No!
Pull it!
[ Grunting ]
Thank you!
Okay.
And it will not
come apart...
until you...
take it apart.
Cuban: Wow.
Corcoran:
Pretty cool.
Herjavec:
Oh, that's cool.
And...
Stop the madness.
[ Chuckles ]
There's more madness.
It leaves
no sticky residue.
Cuban: No!
Yes.
And it's reusable.
If this
was any other kind of tape,
it would be history,
a memory,
but it's Amazing Tape
and it goes right back
to the way that it was.
Hugo's Amazing Tape
is extremely versatile,
with hundreds of uses,
and we're gonna show you
right now.
[ Greiner chuckles ]
Ooh!
Traveling potluck
won't spill in my car,
and it can go in the freezer
and the microwave.
Ah!
[ Southern accent ] Oh,
I just love the way
that it goes around
my embroidery threads,
keeps them
from unraveling.
[ New York accent ]
Sharks, you ever pick up a
power tool and no juice?
[ Laughs ]
You want it,
you unwrap it.
You're done,
you wrap it. Done.
Done.
[ New York accent ] Done.
[ British accent ] Oh, listen,
you know something?
It's wonderful
around your plants.
[ Normal voice ]
Wires and cables everywhere.
[ Sobbing ]
Until Hugo's
helped me get organized.
[ Irish accent ] You
know something? Oh, Mark,
Mark, this one's for you.
You know how sometimes
the kids ‐‐
they're always losin'
the basketball pump?
Well,
you take some Amazing Tape,
and you just wrap it around,
keep them together.
Kath?
[ Normal voice ]
Yeah?
Wrapping paper.
Oh,
wrapping paper!
Wrapping paper.
This is the best way.
People love Amazing Tape
around wrapping paper.
Yeah.
As you can see, Sharks,
the applications are endless,
and the markets
are wide‐open.
And we are an...
all‐season item!
All‐season item!
Yes!                        Yes!
We know
you're gonna use it.
Want some samples?
Yes.
[ British accent ]
I do love giving samples.
[ Applause ]
Wow.
Greiner:
Most entertaining.
Thank you.
There you go,
Mark.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Lori.
Thank you,
Lauri.
Thank you.
Mr. Wonderful.
O'Leary: Thank you so much.
Thanks.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Corcoran:
Robert.
Thank you,
Lauri.
Thank you.
Wow,
it really works.
Corcoran: Wow.
Really does.
Oh, so,
you have to tell us,
first off,
who created it and how.
And who's that guy
in the photo?
Herjavec: And why is it
called Hugo's?
[ Normal voice ]
Hugo is our dad.
Our dad.
Cuban:
You're sisters?
We're sisters.
Yeah.
You're sisters?
Yes.
Yeah.
Our ‐‐ Our father
created this.
Yeah.
And our father
passed away this year.
Right.
Greiner:
Oh, I'm sorry.
Cuban:
I'm sorry.
Yeah, me, too.
And so he invented it about,
would you say 20 years ago?
Oh, wow.
He was
a very creative guy.
Really creative.
And he stumbled across
this tape.
Someone had shipped
something to him.
But he said,
"This stuff is amazing."
He started to do it.
And so
he had it rolled ‐‐
O'Leary: So,
he didn't invent it?
It's PVC.
He made a use for it.
Right, but ‐‐
You know, he took that material
to somebody and said,
"I want to make something,
but I want it to be what you ‐‐"
Herjavec: All right,
so, more directly,
do you or your dad
own the patent for this?
The patent expired
with my father.
Greiner:
I was gonna say.
Yes. Yes.
They only last
20 to 23 years, depending.
20 years.
Both: Yes.
Greiner:
Where are you selling them?
Okay.
And how much
does it cost?
Okay.
We are selling it right now,
uh, online,
and just out of my trunk
at a swap meet,
wherever we can...
Yes, yeah.
...because we both have
other businesses.
That's the packaging?
Is that
the package there?
Cuban:
Could you pass that out?
Yes.
And we'll pass it ‐‐
We'll pass it down here.
And so they come in
1/2‐inch, 1‐inch,
and 2‐inch rolls.
Saltzberg:
That's fine. Yeah.
Okay.
Okay, so, here's 3 feet,
one meter.
We buy that for $1.27,
and it sells for $12.99.
Oh,
that's expensive.
$12.99?
Yes.
Herjavec: What were
the biggest year of sales?
Like, how much was he selling
in his best year?
The ‐‐ The numbers
were very unclear, okay?
O'Leary: Unclear?
$68,000 was the most
they made in a year.
Since, we've sold,
what, $500,000...
Yes.
...since 2011.
'11.
Okay, what about
the last 12 months?
Uh...
$27,500.
Do you have a secret formula,
or do ‐‐
does somebody
make this for you?
And can I call those people
and buy it myself?
Okay.
Cuban: Do you ‐‐
Yeah, do you have ‐‐
I'm not sure about all
this. That's another
reason why we're here.
O'Leary: Yes, you can.
You can call the ‐‐
Where's it manufactured?
O'Leary: I could ‐‐ I could call
those people myself.
Taiwan.
Taiwan?
Oh, then it's definitely
ripped off.
O'Leary: Of course.
Right? Yeah.
Corcoran:
Is this your full‐time job?
Are you guys actors perchance?
Right, we are ‐‐
I am an actor.
I'm also
a parent coach.
And I'm a voiceover artist
and I'm a hairdresser.
Oh, okay.
So I would be
in my hair salon.
All my clients
buy Amazing Tape.
I ‐‐
I answer the phone,
I'm doing hair,
and I say, "Excuse me."
[ Chuckles ]
"Hugo's Amazing Tape.
Can I help you?"
[ Southern accent ]
"This is Nell.
I'd like one roll
of 2‐inch tape."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] "I'll be
right back, I'll be right back.
Yeah, can I just get your ‐‐
and your credit card?"
And we're lucky.
And here it goes.
That's how it goes.
I‐I get it, I get it.
It ‐‐
It's very crazy chicken, okay?
I thought it was
the best bad theater
we've ever had
on "Shark Tank."
And we've had
a lot of bad theater.
But this
was good bad theater, and...
Okay.
...that was fun, but this is
not really a business.
Well...
[ Corcoran chuckles ]
I'm out.
♪♪
Are you sure about that?
I'm pretty sure.
[ Laughter ]
You know, I just wanted
to say something.
When my father passed, I said,
"This is my dad's legacy."
I mean, he was a creative guy,
and he deserves this, you know,
for everyone to see
that he created Amazing Tape.
But we would love to
get it out there, 'cause
it's a ‐‐ it's an ‐‐
That's very nice.
You're honoring his memory.
Yes, but it's also an ‐‐
it's also an incredible...
product.
Product.
[ Chuckles ]
Katherine, Lauri,
I love how you're doing it
with the memory of your dad,
but I'm not sure
what the business is.
You lost me on the patent,
how you're distributing it.
I‐I got to tell you,
this is so crazy a story
that it's perfect
for one of the Sharks here.
Oh, I ‐‐ I have to ‐‐
And I appreciate ‐‐
Not me, not me.
I'm out.
♪♪
Th‐This is
the kind of thing
that Barbara loves
to get her hands into...
Corcoran: Oh.
...and make
something of it.
Yeah, here's what I like
about it, okay?
See?
I ‐‐ I didn't say
I'm getting into it.
You are.
I'm just telling you
what I like about it.
I took water and I wet
the exterior of my glass,
thinking,
"Ah, there's a catch here.
If it gets wet,
it doesn't work."
Hmm.
And I pulled up my glass,
and it held.
Really?
Saltzberg: Yeah.
And I took it off,
and there's no residue
on the glass whatsoever.
Thank you.
Yes.
What I think you have here
is a business you ought
to get rid of, honestly.
It's a potential business
that neither of you
really want to wrestle with.
I'm out, so...
O'Leary: Ooh, well,
it's not over yet.
Herjavec: Surprising.
Mark and Lori, are you ready
for Hugo's Amazing Tape?
Mark and I
have been talking.
We have an offer
to make you
because we think
this has a lot of potential.
A lot of risk.
But a lot of potential.
Ooh.
What we'd like to do
is buy the entire company...
Whoa.
Herjavec: Wow.
♪♪
...for the $100,000.
So, rather than 50K
for 50%,
we'll give you $100,000
for the whole thing,
and we'll take care
of Hugo, um, legacy.
♪♪
You're gonna say...
You're not kidding,
right?
Nope.
[ Laughter ]
This is ‐‐ This is really
happening right now.
We have to
think about it.
♪♪
Oh!
She's kidding.
[ Chuckles ]
Yes.
Thank you so much.
Yes. Yes!
Oh, my God!
Yes!
Yes! Yes! Yes!
Corcoran: Wow.
Oh, my gosh!
Thank you so much.
You did
a great job.
It's really cool.
You bought a lot of tape.
[ Chuckles ]
Oh!
Thank you so much.
[ Laughs ]
Great job.
Thank you,
thank you.
Congratulations, guys.
Doing really well.
Thank you guys. Oh! Oh, my God!
Oh, my God!
Lauri, Lauri,
calm down, it's okay.
Okay.
This is amazing.
Saltzberg: Our father, Hugo,
would be so incredibly proud.
This one's for you.
[ Chuckles ]
[ Sniffles ] Yeah.
I got to ask,
with all the problems we heard,
why did you guys buy
the entire company?
Cuban:
I loved it.
It's first to market.
That's what it's all about.
That's what
we're really good at.
You just paid 100 grand
for basically poop on a stick.
[ Laughter ]
I'm not kidding.
[ Muffled ]
It's poop on a stick.
It's a very bad deal.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the tank
is a functional twist
to personal transportation.
Ah. [ Chuckles ]
O'Leary: Gosh.
Corcoran: Wow.
What is that?
Wow.
If that
isn't Robert...
For the airport?
[ Chuckles ]
Cuban:
Go get him, Robert.
Hi.
My name is Tony Chan.
I'm from
Los Angeles, California.
My company is Coolpeds USA.
Today I'm asking $250,000
for 5% of our company.
Wow.
I design and make
the world's coolest
and lightest electric vehicles,
like this ‐‐
the world's first
super lightweight
electric briefcase‐scooter.
You can ride it to
and from train station...
[ Cuban chuckles ]
...from the office
to the parking lot,
to classes on a huge campus,
and even to the boarding gate
at the airport,
all without
carrying a heavy backpack,
and having so much fun.
Yeah.
[ Cuban chuckles ]
[ Light laughter ]
The bag is easily removable.
And you can go from
a leisurely 7 miles per hour
up to 15 miles per hour.
Wow.
And with regenerative braking,
when you press the handle brake,
right here, it will actually
recharge the battery.
Yeah.
Speak of the battery,
it is also very easily removable
so you can charge it
almost anywhere.
And you can even charge
your phone.
The scooter itself is
really easy to fold like this.
And weighing just 11 pounds,
it is the lightest
electric scooters on the planet.
My mission is to provide fun,
reliable, and affordable
green transportation
to everyone around the globe.
So, who's ready to get moving?
Anyone would like
to give it a ride?
O'Leary:
I want to try it, Tony.
Ah, I want to try it, too,
after Kevin.
♪♪
O'Leary: Very cool.
Chan: Thank you.
That's interesting.
Awesome.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
Herjavec: He's gonna hit
the camera.
It doesn't tip that much.
Whoa, oh.
He's good.
[ Laughs ]
That's really good.
Close the doors!
Herjavec:
[ Laughter ]
Close the door!
Awesome.
He's awesome.
[ Chuckles ]
Nice. One‐handed.
Pretty fast.
I'm impressed.
Yeah, 'cause he ‐‐
Yeah, you ‐‐
Is that
the fast mode?
It's really easy to control,
just with this trigger.
Very cool.
The more you press, the faster.
It's like a motorcycle.
Greiner: How did it feel?
Very cool.
Easy.
Tony?
Chan: Yes?
What's under
the gray sheet?
[ Greiner chuckles ]
Great ‐‐ Great question.
Uh, this is the future.
Let me introduce to you
the future
of the automobile industry.
Oh,
that's beautiful.
The Ampere.
Greiner:
Oh, my God.
Wow.
World's first ‐‐
first fully electric
highway‐ready sports car
for under $10,000 retail.
Yeah.
Oh, wow.
We're gonna change the
auto industry to the Model "T."
Greiner:
Wait a minute.
Yeah.
We'll make it simple.
What are you selling ‐‐
that or that?
Both.
Both?
This is our next product.
This is our prototype.
It's a running prototype.
I've been driving ‐‐
Whoo‐hoo!
Whoa!
You're a racer.
I know you love cars...
Really.
...but I can't even
get in that quick.
It's cool.
That was
so unexpected.
Yeah.
O'Leary: So, let's take
one product at a time.
This scooter ‐‐ tell me what
you're gonna sell this year.
Sure.
In the past about 18 months,
we've sold about $500,000 worth
of scooter.
And where are you selling
most of those at?
Mostly online.
Is that the only
piece of luggage that
you could put on that?
Can I use my own,
individual luggage?
Actually,
um, we have different styles.
We would like
to provide our own luggage,
just for safety reasoning.
It has to be really rigid.
Did you tell us the price
on that scooter?
Oh, sorry.
$399.
$399? Thank you.
O'Leary: And what does it
cost you, landed, here?
Chan: About $170.
Oh.
There's not enough margin
for distribution.
Right, so, that's why we ‐‐
we just want to go online,
'cause this is great for online.
Did you ‐‐
Did you file a patent on this?
Yeah, I have a patent ‐‐
material patent.
O'Leary: So, Tony,
let's take some airports
where a lot of walking occurs.
Are ‐‐ Are they going to allow
an electric vehicle?
Chan:
I do it all the time.
I've never been stopped,
actually.
Actually, from my experience
and a lot
of my customers' experience,
they ride slowly.
Just don't hit anybody
or do crazy stunts, you know?
[ Laughs ]
Herjavec:
What's your background?
Are you an engineer?
I love cars.
Cars are in my blood.
Me, too.
When I was 7 ‐‐
I know, exactly ‐‐
I started waxing cars
for my neighbors
to make pocket money
when I was 7 ‐‐ 7 years old.
And then,
fast‐forward to college at UCLA,
I started to buy classic cars
and repair them
and then resold them
to make profit
for almost four years
of my tuition
and almost all my expenses.
And then I raced cars
and built racecars on the side
for over 15 years.
So I built up a lot
of relationship resource.
Robert, you can go ahead
and make your offer right now.
[ Laughter ]
This is gonna revolutionize
the electric‐car industry,
which is booming.
A lot of countries, like France,
the U. K., even China,
they will require all cars
to be sold to be all electric
as early as 2025.
But you're not ‐‐ you're not
selling the electric car yet.
Right, we're gonna start
taking pre‐orders this year.
I'm just curious, what does
that car cost somebody?
This one,
we're gonna retail at $9,900.
On this first model,
we would like to make it
a really extravagant racecar.
We follow the Tesla model.
It started with the Roadster
in a small batch and then built,
because it's a cool image.
Now, they want to be cool.
Cuban: Tony,
this is a brutally,
brutally competitive market,
right?
The three hardest businesses
in the world
are, one,
the music business,
two, anything involving
Kevin O'Leary...
[ Laughter ]
...and three,
selling cool.
♪♪
That's what
you're selling here, right?
You're a grinder
that loves what you're doing,
and I respect that,
but I'd be a fool
to try to sell cool.
So, for those reasons,
I'm out.
♪♪
You know, I'm concerned about
both of these products.
I don't know why
you put them together, honestly.
I think
it confuses the issue.
I've never been
in an airport
and seen anyone
on a scooter,
except some
official capacity.
And if there's 500 people
on these,
I think there's gonna be
issues with it.
Or I would at least
like to know
definitely you could ride it
at the airport,
and I don't think your answer
was very clear.
Yeah, um ‐‐
I think
you have such a long way to go.
Yeah.
Long way to go.
Well,
can I tell you a‐a ‐‐
So I'm out.
...story ‐‐
because there's a similar car.
So I'm out,
yeah.
♪♪
First of all, I don't think
I've ever been so surprised
at what an entrepreneur
brought in front of us,
because they're
completely different arenas.
I think your heart
is in selling that car.
I don't think
it has to do with the scooter.
The scooter
is a means to an end.
And I‐I‐I wouldn't even know
what to do with that car.
For that reason,
I'm out.
♪♪
I'm ‐‐ I think that
the scooter/suitcase market
is a full‐time job.
I mean, just to market that
is a heck of a challenge.
And 5% doesn't even get me out
of bed to get on the scooter.
I mean,
that's just nothing burger.
And what do you suggest?
No, I've ‐‐
Tony, you know, I ‐‐
You have a car guy here
in Herjavec.
I'm out.
[ Sighs ]
Robert?
Herjavec: Tony,
you're such an impressive guy,
and we share
the car passion.
You started
this incredible business.
You're doing half a million
a year in sales.
I mean,
you're doing it.
I want
to come along.
Yes, i really want you
to come along, seriously.
[ Laughter ]
I‐I'm just not sure ‐‐
Owning a car company
is really cool,
and we start selling, yes.
It's ‐‐
It's just a little confusing,
and I mean that
with the most respect.
This ‐‐
The business
you brought out today
really is the scooter business
with a passion business, and ‐‐
Oh, this is
my main business entry.
Corcoran:
Yeah, it shows.
The scooter was, like,
a pre, you know, show.
That really shows,
and that's hard for an investor.
This is my passion.
Tony, I‐I ‐‐
O'Leary:
Make a decision, Robert.
I ‐‐ I can't come along
for a ride
on the scooter
and the car.
Well ‐‐
It's got to be one.
You got to focus.
The car is the major,
for sure.
I'm out.
I'm sorry.
Cuban:
Congrats, Tony.
You've come
a long way, buddy.
Thank you very much.
You should be
very proud.
Thank you.
Leave the scooter.
Greiner:
You'll keep going far.
[ Chuckles ]
Thank you.
♪♪
Would have been nice
with Robert onboard,
but we have a massive plan
in place.
We're gonna help a lot of people
to get around
in a green and cool way.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a solution
for unwanted loose change.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Jeff Witten.
I'm from Mamaroneck, New York,
and my company is CoinOut.
I'm seeking $250,000
in exchange for a 7 1/2 stake ‐‐
a 7 1/2% stake of my company.
Sharks, we've all been here.
You're paying
for your iced latte
at the local coffee joint ‐‐
hey, there ‐‐
and your morning is off
to a great start...
[ Chuckles ]
...until this moment.
Getting back loose change.
Oh! I hate loose change.
Me, too.
It's filthy,
it doesn't fit in your wallet
or your skinny jeans.
Getting coins back from cash
is a completely inefficient,
annoying, and stupid way...
That's right.
...to transact.
Instead, turn your loose change
into easy money with CoinOut,
the most convenient way
to digitize your loose change.
We're getting rid
of those pesky pennies,
allowing people to take
full control over their money.
Let me show you how it works.
So, you're paying with cash
at a participating merchant,
and your change is $1.34.
After handing over the cash,
you simply ask the cashier,
"I'd like to CoinOut."
When she turns a device, you
simply enter your phone number
into the device at checkout,
and you can choose if you want
to CoinOut just the coins ‐‐
the 34 cents ‐‐
or the full change ‐‐
the $1.34 ‐‐
to your CoinOut wallet.
Hit "Confirm" and ‐‐ boom ‐‐
transaction's complete.
You'll get a text message
confirming the transaction,
along with instructions to set
up your account online later.
And the best part is,
there's no app to download,
no financial information needed,
and no sign‐up required
until you're ready to cash out.
Sharks, carrying around coins
simply doesn't make sense.
So the next time you check out,
CoinOut.
Greiner: Interesting.
O'Leary: Can I pay
with my CoinOut account
next time
I go to get a coffee?
That's one of the options.
So, we have four cash‐out
options right now for customers.
You can transfer it
to your bank account,
you can turn it into
an Amazon gift card,
you can donate to charity,
or, the last option,
is redeeming it in store.
Wow. Why ‐‐ Why is it good
for retail?
Jeff, why are you not
gonna get crushed like
a cockroach in this?
How can you possibly beat
the giant payment operators
long‐term?
So, I'll tell you why.
O'Leary: Please.
Num‐‐ First of all,
cash is not new.
That's your answer?
No one has done this.
The reason why no one's
done this is because, look,
everyone in the industry
thinks cash is going away,
but it's not.
Nobody thinks cash
is going away.
All the ‐‐
Even the bitcoin freaks
don't think cash is going away.
I‐I ‐‐ Mark,
with all due respect ‐‐
You are going
to get crushed.
Mr. Wonderful,
with all due respect,
we're not gonna get crushed.
The technology we've built,
it's ‐‐
of course, it can be replicated,
but it's difficult to build.
Okay?
[ Chuckles ]
You also ‐‐
You need a banking relationship
and you need
a regulatory structure in place
that's not straightforward.
I feel like
I'm at a funeral!
Why would that retailer
have that screen there?
Right.
What's in it
for them?
First of all, cash is
very expensive for the retailer.
So, think about,
from getting delivery ‐‐
armored‐truck delivery
of all the coins.
This happens
at my local pizzeria?
They get an armored‐truck
delivery for their coins?
It's ‐‐ It's crazy.
It's so expensive.
The cost is number one.
Number two is this is
an effective loyalty program
for the retailer.
Loyal ‐‐ So, number two ‐‐
Jeff, I just want to know
if the barista is ‐‐
Oh, my God.
Cuban: Let him get ‐‐
Kevin, him her talk.
Witten: So, there's ‐‐
Number two ‐‐
The barista is looking
at fear at you...
Corcoran:
Let him talk.
...because she knows
a dead man walking.
Witten: Kevin, with all
due respect, let me finish.
Yes.
So, the number two,
the loyalty program,
is key for these guys, okay?
We build the connective tissue
between the merchant
and the cash customer
that's previously anonymous.
I think
it's a great idea.
I hate
carrying change.
That's because
you're rich.
[ Laughter ]
Walk me through
how you make money at it.
What's the revenue model?
Well, the business model,
we charge merchants
20 bucks a month,
and then we are also earning ‐‐
20 bucks a month?
20 bucks a month.
We also earn 3%
on each transaction.
Oh!
So, let me tell you
my experience, all right?
And this actually goes back
to "Shark Tank."
I was in law school.
I was on the path
to become a corporate lawyer.
And I watched
the Scrub Daddy episode.
Whoo‐hoo!
[ Chuckles ]
I have my property textbook
next to me.
And I'm looking at this guy,
and this guy is just teeming
with emotion and energy.
And I'm like, "Wow.
This guy, like, he really cares
about what he's invested in."
And I said, "I want to be
the next Scrub Daddy."
I really did.
And this has been a long,
drawn‐out process.
I studied the market.
But ‐‐
Okay, hold on. I had
a full‐time offer at Apple.
[ Chuckles ]
Turned it down.
Full‐time clear path to
corporate law, turned it down.
I've got a ton invested in this.
I'm relentless.
How much
do you have ‐‐
How much do you have
invested in it?
We raised $460,000 ‐‐ family,
friends, some of my own money.
Okay, so, Jeff,
here's what I'm hearing.
People want to use
alternative payment systems
to simplify
their lives, right?
The issue for you
is getting people
to use your application.
Agreed.
That's not cheap.
And you're trying
to get 20 bucks a month
out of all the applications that
that barista could possibly run.
But ‐‐ Okay, fair ‐‐
fair points.
However,
change is a big problem.
No one's solved it,
and to redistribute ‐‐
Okay, let me just tell you
how I solved it.
Here's my credit card.
Okay, fine, fine, okay,
but, however,
the numbers
tell a different story, Mark.
32% of all U. S. transactions
are still done in cash.
Herjavec: Absolutely.
32%?
30‐‐ That's more than credit,
more than debit.
It's in the merchants' interest
to do more
of these transactions.
Data is king in this world.
If you go
to any major coffee chain,
only 15%
are on their loyalty program.
They're not accessing
any of these customers
that are paying with cash,
'cause they don't want
to download an app.
Big merchants
are going to love this.
I got to give this kid
a compliment.
I don't think
I've ever seen anybody
go one‐on‐one
with the Sharks.
You know,
you basically dismissed Kevin.
He got reprimanded
by you.
You treat Mark as though he's
your equal here. Good for you.
No, it was ‐‐
it was fine.
I've never seen a kid come
in here ‐‐ Good for you.
Herjavec: Jeff, you come
out here, we told you ‐‐
All of that doesn't matter
if you just get a deal.
We told you ‐‐
You've won my respect.
We told you
everything that's wrong with it.
Yeah, you keep coming back.
Tell us what's working.
Four months ‐‐ okay? ‐‐
we've done 2,500 transactions.
The customers that use it
love it and are coming back.
The problem
you're really solving
is for people
who don't like change.
Which is everyone.
The loyalty and the other stuff
is a benefit.
Witten: Yeah.
But that's
the fundamental problem, right?
Yes, for sure.
The part where you
put in the phone number...
Yes.
...and stored it,
and then you use that
in the cloud
to accumulate everything,
right?
Yes.
Clever.
The best part of everything
you've told me is that ‐‐
the idea
that for any loyalty program,
the barista just says,
"Put in your phone number.
If and when
you decide to join,
you're gonna have accumulated
all these benefits,
and we'll track."
Yeah.
That's brilliant.
The fact that you're focused on
CoinOut is horrific.
♪♪
I‐I disagree.
It's not ‐‐
I know you disagree.
You're trying to get both
a consumer to be aware of it
and the barista
to also be aware of it.
The fact that you just
focused on one feature
of what could be
a bigger solution,
I have
a real problem with.
Okay.
I'm out.
Yeah.
Greiner:
I hate coins.
I don't even like
to carry money, period.
So I'm definitely like
your customer.
It could take off,
or it could just fizzle, right?
And I don't know how I'm gonna
get my $250,000 back.
I'm sorry.
I'm out.
That's fair enough.
Look, if we get
to 100,000 locations ‐‐
which in the franchise model,
if it works,
the dominoes start falling,
you can get to ‐‐
that's a $30 million run rate.
The big retail, at the time ‐‐
the time is now.
These guys are dying
for something like this.
How long would it take you
to get 1,000 retailers?
We expect
to get into 700 locations
by the end of this year.
Next year,
we expect to get to 3,000.
I totally believe you're gonna
make this thing happen.
♪♪
I'm going to give you
your $250,000 for 15%,
but it's contingent
on you getting those locations
by year‐end,
because that's the missing key
to this whole program.
Appreciate ‐‐
Appreciate your offer.
Get the locations.
With all due respect,
the contingency there
is untenable.
Cuban: Oh!
Why not?
Untenable?
You said
you would get it.
I‐I'm not gonna do a contingency
based on locations.
O'Leary: Whoa.
♪♪
Narrator:
Two Sharks are out.
Jeff has an offer from Barbara
for his platform for eliminating
loose change, CoinOut,
but he doesn't like
the contingency
she placed on the offer,
even though it's based on
the numbers he projected.
Witten:
With all due respect,
the contingency there
is untenable.
Cuban: Oh!
Why not?
Untenable?
But you said
you would get it.
I‐I'm not gonna do a contingency
based on locations.
Whoa.
But you said
you could get the locations.
I don't get that.
And I believe I can,
but it's not in my interest.
But you don't believe it enough
to make the deal dependent ‐‐
No, no, no,
that's doesn't mean that.
A lawyer.
I'm very confident
in this business.
If you ‐‐ If you don't see ‐‐
But I'm losing the confidence
when you say that.
This is a long‐‐ This is a ‐‐
This is a long‐term vision.
If it's gonna be contingent
on getting a number
within six months,
then I don't think
you fully believe in the vision.
You don't.
No, no, I do.
I believed in you until you said
you didn't believe.
Mr. Wonderful, you would never
make that sort of a deal.
But if it was the only offer
I had, I might consider it.
Corcoran: You said no.
O'Leary: You don't have
the confidence to get there
that you suggested earlier.
Gosh,
I love Jeff.
I do have the confidence.
When I borrowed money
for my business,
I guaranteed that I'd
pay them back within six months.
But ‐‐ But ‐‐
And I would have never taken
the original $1,000
unless I felt
entirely sure
I would find some way
to get that money back
to that investor.
Fair enough, fair enough,
of course.
Jeff, fair enough,
but I'm out, yeah.
Okay.
Okay, Jeff,
I'm gonna make you an offer.
You wouldn't take
a contingency deal at 15%.
How much pain
are you willing to take?
♪♪
If you don't have
that confidence
and you don't want
a contingency,
I'll do the $250,000
for 25%.
Thank you for your offer.
Um, I'd love to see if there are
any other offers on the table.
Fine. But because
it should cost you 10%,
if you're not willing
to be confident enough
to scale at the rate
you believed
when you came in here ‐‐
I'm gonna be honest,
Mr. Wonderful,
I haven't felt the love from you
today at all.
Oh!
Witten: So, I‐I don't need
to know if I should be ‐‐
Jeff, it's not about love,
it's about money.
Yeah, but ‐‐ but you need to be
my partner in this, so ‐‐
Look ‐‐
There's been nothing
that you've said today
to convey that you're at all
interested in the business.
Herjavec: Jeff,
when I started my business,
my bank said,
"Every quarter,
you have to hit
a certain level of sales
for us to continue
to give you the money."
Of course.
If I didn't hit them,
they wanted their money back.
Of course.
Maybe the 700 locations
is too much of a stretch.
Okay.
But you've got
to prove it out.
Sure.
So I'll give you the $250,000,
15% equity,
but I want to see
a successful pilot
with a
large‐scale retailer.
Appreciate your offer.
Thank you very much.
I think it's a fair contingency.
How about, would ‐‐
would you come down to, um ‐‐
[Scoffs] ‐‐ I would do 10%.
And look, I think ‐‐
$250,000, 15%.
Your other offer
is $250,000 for 25% from Kevin.
Agreed, but, look,
I think we've proven
that ‐‐ that the technology
is pretty cool.
This is a huge idea, a huge
market. I don't think you ‐‐
Jeff, he's not gonna move.
You got to make a decision.
Hold on. Can I finish?
O'Leary:
Not gonna move.
[ Chuckling ]
I‐I'm not gonna move.
You're not gonna move at all
at 15%?
That ‐‐ That's ‐‐
You've watched "Shark Tank."
You know he's not moving.
Witten:
I would ‐‐ I would ‐‐
You're in the world
of theory.
So, yeah, my ‐‐
I need to see that world
get into reality.
My maximum, in my head,
was 12 1/2%.
Can you come down
to 12 1/2%?
So, hang ‐‐
hang on a second.
You were willing
to give up 12 1/2%,
but for the other 2 1/2%,
you're not willing
to make that ‐‐
The 12 1/2% was the highest
that I wanted to go.
Jeff, it ‐‐
I'm a simple guy.
Okay, so, let ‐‐
So, fine.
It's 15%.
It ‐‐ It ‐‐
You know what?
Can I just ‐‐
I have one contingency.
♪♪
If we do the deal,
Kevin can't use the product.
[ Laughter ]
I'll do it at 15%.
Done.
All right.
Cuban:
Congratulations, Jeff.
Greiner:
[ Chuckles ]
This is awesome. Thank you.
Good job.
Cuban: Congrats, Jeff.
Good luck.
Greiner:
Congrats, Jeff.
Whew.
I'm pumped.
I'm really pumped
to have Robert onboard.
He's the perfect Shark,
and we're gonna crush it.
"Shark Tank" has been a part
of my story the whole way.
It's part of
the inspiration here.
And with Robert onboard,
we're gonna be Scrub Daddy 2.
♪♪